in Indonesia living with the volcano is
part of who we are
the fortune is a symbol of the place
where the gods stays
we don't know when we don't know why but
at some point they they just awaken
the volcano creates the most fertile
soil on earth and we great instructions
come with reward it comes life
the volcano also bring to life and now
the resource mines
I fail at some point we take too much
this anger the got an eruption hundreds
of tremors were recorded today with the
threat level and its hires to stay at
natural disaster has already made to
Clara Valley all the 48,000 people
evacuated taking refuge in shelters
the condition inside the camps
they are not easy many of us we've been
forced to leave our home we don't know
for how long but as indonesian people we
are strong and we will continue to pray
God will show us the way
for us to be free from the volcano
we must not fear its presence instead we
must respect the gods
we're taking care of our environment
taking care of our people but still we
can never know when the God will awaken